a little better oh yeah yeah you look
beautiful we're alive hello good
afternoon good morning good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel it's just me and
Harris you know just hanging out another
day so my children hate me so um
they like they're just leaving me alone
for now and uh Paris hasn't got any
children that we know about
one day soon
um but we're gonna be talking Stargate
Universe and we're gonna put this damn
argument to bed if it kills us or kills
everyone else let's do it let's do it
[Music]
it was boring
it just was
I tried to like it I really tried to
like it but I'm gonna I'm gonna put a
caveat on this though right I am all
comparing Stargate Universe to sg1 and
Stargate Atlantis right okay if we
compare it to all of the other sci-fi my
argument changes dramatically
because compared to most of the other
sci-fi it's way better
but compared to sg1 and SG Atlantis
it wasn't it wasn't good enough
um but you've watched it recently yes
what do you think
I think where it it could be arguable as
it is boring in places I think it's much
more of you're you're and I don't mean
this in a bad way howdy howdy David uh
it's it's I don't like saying the word
generic but it's it's a it's a generic
Slow Burn it's not a generic Sci-Fi
series or anything it has generic
qualities to aspects of it but I feel
like it is a yeah start slow integrate
it it was just a slow burn you know and
that's why it starts a little slow it
takes a second to pick up and by the end
you're like
why are we stopping it why are we
putting people in stasis I I will argue
I will I will argue like I've always
said like the first definitely the first
season of Star Trek the Next Generation
wasn't right
but they fixed it so by the end of the
season all of a suddenly Geordie laforge
um got a load of engineering
qualifications from nowhere and they
made him chief engineer he was the pilot
made him chief engineer that is a you
know a
that's a you know a curve a learner I
mean wow he just got promoted like whoa
um and then they moved
sorry they replaced the pilot right
they've kind of never really had another
like regular pilot they just sort of had
people sitting there
and then but there was always you know
they were never in Star Trek they were
never that like focused on data would be
sat in the um and he was supposed to be
anybody okay okay break over sometimes
um but but yeah so um but they rejigged
it and it made it work I think they did
similar for SGU and let's say what we're
put to bed first of all why it got
canceled
it got canceled not because it was
rubbish or because no one was watching
it that's just not true and anybody that
says that's why I got consulted it's
just not right it got canceled because
MGM went under
and the show is becoming too expensive
to make basically just for sci-fi on
their own and that is why it got
canceled the numbers actually weren't
terrible they were not up there with SGU
or SG Atlantis even actually they're
about the same as SG Atlantis towards
the end okay so that's why it got
canceled it was simply money all right
um because not only it was MGM but
sci-fi was rebranding and there were
like it was The Perfect Storm I think as
we recorded a couple times right yeah
and I think um there was just no one
else willing to pick it up sort of thing
but the main I think that honestly the
main thing was MGM was genuinely didn't
know it was going to exist
within the next 12 months that's how bad
it was I mean MGM basically there after
SGU got canceled limped along
for the next 10 years really owned by
its creditors which is never a good
position to be in no
um sold a bunch of stuff off and then
Amazon came along
um you know but um it it limped along
focusing on things like
it's focused on its big Brands
just about managed to get a bond couple
of Bond movies out
um and it and it did a lot of reality TV
and it you know and it just about got by
um
but anyway
yeah legally blind three was the thing
that really put it under right
oh no that's that's going to get it back
on top maybe exactly it's gonna bring it
right back I can't wait to do our review
on that I mean that's going to be a
whole week videos for us
I watch along with Legally Blonde one
and two
um and then and then we have breakdowns
of each of course
and it's character and everything and
you know we have to really get stuck
into the legal system because the second
one is much and the first one's about
legal systems I've watched these films
that's really embarrassing first ones
about legal systems the senate or
something
[Music]
um but yeah she gets into the legal
system yeah I I get that confused with
Beverly Hills Chihuahua after the first
one
I don't I don't think I've seen Beverly
Australia but we're going off topic
exactly
but we should do that with maybe not
super super super in depth necessarily
as much as we feel like it but with
Stargate Universe whenever yes whatever
we get back well let's get into just
first of all was it any good that's
today's question so before we get into
that I did put a
um
rate SGU question on the Community page
yesterday and I will ask people
basically rate it from one to five
up there is the best as one and five it
was Bloody awful
um so we've had 1.4
000 votes of 1400 votes not bad not bad
not shabby at all I'm gonna ask you guys
to guess or ask you how to guess
how many people said that it's up there
with the best and and you're saying one
is best in five
okay
people do you think said it was the best
I'm gonna go with
14 to 18
and then there's no understanding but
then the second best I think or is it
like a one two three four five option or
what yeah one two three four five well
then number two I'm guessing like 20 25
percent maybe 30 percent
no no
is it the opposite I'm bored by this
channel I'm buying by this channel I'm
bored but actually I did get a comment
yeah this channel is boring
but we're clipping it
um yeah yeah don't click that below
um 33 of people said it's up there were
the best 34 of people who said it was
good uh 22 of people said it was okay
eight percent of people said not the
best and only four percent of people
said it was awful
and 1400 votes so that ain't bad
um
yeah you you should have a little bit
more confidence in the show that you've
recently lost and loved so much dammit I
just thought it would be like one two
three would be like 20 40 60 or or Earth
City 70 80 altogether or something and
then the next two would be like fill in
and out a little bit more but I I like
those numbers those numbers make me
happy
yes they make you happy you just jumped
out the shower so you're gonna get clean
and happy we did yes we started this
video for 10 minutes earlier I know
certain somebody that is normally in the
in the comments it would have been very
happy but um
my main problem
with this the whole series whole series
it was have you have you actually seen
the rebooted version of Battlestar
Galactica I haven't seen either right
what you must watch the
um at least the mini series that's the
best bit it wanders a bit when it gets
into the series but the mini series they
did that's Edward James almost and Katie
Sackhoff right yes yeah I'm some of the
best of my five I made
um I always felt the SGU was um that
Brad Wright and everybody that was
involved saw Battlestar galactone Court
that's bloody marvelous that is let's do
that
and it it very it felt very much like in
style not obviously in story and Etc but
in style
it felt like Battlestar Galactica and it
was it but it was noticeable
sort of thing
um shaky camera shot
um no noise in space you know she'll
have these like these silent almost
shots whether you know shuttles are
flying by and things
I I found that
it just it was just such a change in
style and tone that it felt
um
there was some scary moments when I
talked about Chloe in a second
um ah the British accent is cute it's
because I'm British
see box of tea and there's room there's
a lot of room in this just waiting room
I had it was the bottom of the bottle
and I just thought that's that's I need
you know that's that I'd only leave it
piddly look that means but it was like
it was like to there what what room do
y'all drink over uh across the pond
um this is a spice drum
um this is uh this is one that they sell
in Aldi it's one of a bunch of rewards
but I can't say what's I can't remember
um shake a camera the gold cargo ship
going through hyperspace soda they went
too far with that silliness yeah but it
played so well into the series as well
because it it gave
they didn't Eli didn't need something to
do he was the math boy he could have
been doing engineering stuff the entire
time but it gave him a hobby that made
him more of a individual and a realized
full like person and and he in turn made
every other character on the show fully
realized and felt more like an
individual person and not so much just a
okay we're gonna need this person on two
episodes to kill off here and we're
gonna need this person in five episodes
to kill off here so we don't have to
hurt our main cast
made each one of them uh more
individualistic what I and and I
I would still probably put SGU as my
least favorite of the three I really do
like it but it character development
wise in two seasons did what the other
shows couldn't do in five or ten because
of the way that they handled that shaky
cam so I I don't necessarily see it as
like the best thing ever
but it served its purpose and served its
purpose very well is it one of those
things with the change of toe and and I
think anybody would argue I don't think
anybody can argue sorry that it wasn't a
massive change in turn between the first
two that are very similar in tone and
style and then SG very very different
but after two shows did they have to do
it do they have to have
to do something different and is it one
of those things that
they were damned if they did and damned
if they didn't
then do they do damn it they don't but I
was it was I I think
what's what what's our guy say you know
what's what's Brad Wright say he said
they had to do something different and
if we're all in the the mindset of trust
Brad trust Brad I trust Brad I think he
he knew that they couldn't do another
copycat show and it's not that Stargate
Atlantis was a copycat show but if they
were gonna do something in like totally
the same vein
it would have been a copycat show or
Atlantis had enough different
differentiation
third time's not a charm in that way
third time's a charm to get you like
fully canceled and that still happened
here uh and part of that might have been
because that we talked about like
aesthetically wise it doesn't feel
Stargate for the most part the actual
formula and the things they're doing is
very Stargate it is different than the
way they typically do it from like a
bass type thing but it is very much
still Stargate so I I don't know if it
was too copycat in that sense which
still got it canceled
um or it was obviously the whole Fiasco
of behind the scenes I mean you got very
much into the basics of go through gate
visit worlds that look an awful lot like
either a sand Quarry or Montana
um oh sorry or you know um Northwest
California or something
um and um British Columbia
um do whatever you got to do and then
move on but I mean I think
Stargate Universe had the overarch and
storyline far more than SGU initiated
both of those stories did have an enemy
that was like you know The Wraith in SGA
and all the storylines that that did
sort of hold everything together but
yeah she was a little bit more in your
face
for me
um but the problem for me was that the
overwriting storyline was can we stay
alive
and that was boring
it was sort of like oh we need to get
some water okay fine gargas and water
yeah markets open down the road just go
get someone from there you know it was
you know I mean it was like there was a
whole episode about the having to power
because it was solar powered so without
to get so close this down it was just in
these things that it was it was but it
was procedural
yes but but not procedural and like uh
because SG-1 and SGA are very procedural
as well but their procedural and like
they could turn into I mean we're
typically doing the same military type
unit tactics every single time yada yada
and it turns into a military uh a law
show or a a doctor show depending on
what's going on at the time and it it it
still feels kind of procedural in that
way where SGU is just
procedural in their approach I guess
generally but I'd argue that that's good
procedural sci-fi compared to like sg1
and SGA where they're it feels like
different elements of different genres
are being imbued inside of sg1 which is
one of the reasons it's so great and
same thing with SGA is it anybody can
have anybody that likes any type of show
will like at least an episode or three
or four or five of those shows where
they might not fresh to you because it
is it's very consistent within all
itself
but it's procedural nonetheless but I I
think it's that Slow Burn procedural
sci-fi and it's it's the thing that kind
of pushes it along
and I think comparison is what kills it
is just because the first two are so so
fun and this one is is where it does get
boring with like okay we have to do this
to survive so we have to go this way we
have to do this to survive so it has to
go that way it's the only series with
Stakes the only time really there are
steaks besides that is maybe when the
aurai come in
I can't really think of that besides
Atlantis maybe having to move planets
the once and then come back to the uh
Earth but
it it it it felt
where sg1 and SGA are very like real in
in a lot of ways it feels like oh this
kind of could be happening maybe like ah
this is fun sgu's like hey once you get
all this stuff this is what it would be
like and I I think it it added realism
to where they were going and where they
had come from which was nice I think
there was an added realism to the thing
and there was
um and the tension they brought into the
situation constantly being attacked the
stress of like
yeah you have you have not only there's
like not only just I guess citizens and
Military which is what it's typically
kind of aligned as but there's a clear
science part too like not only is Rush
kind of in his own camp but Eli's kind
of in Russia's Camp Chloe kind of ends
up in Rutgers camp and there's kind of
that third Camp that's part of the
citizens Works alongside the military
and it's it's
it's them that are almost playing both
sides but both sides really should be
listening to the scientists to survive
anyway right now they and they all know
that but they don't want to give up
their kind of
they don't want to give up their
individuality and their control over
their own like autonomy on the ship in a
way and I don't blame them but you gotta
survive
let's talk about the characters the
actors because I mean we had some
um brilliant acting in this I mean I've
forgotten the guy's name I should have
written his name the guy that played
Colonel young in this Louis Pereira
Louis Ferreira thank you how did I
forget that because it always reminds me
of the guy that played the Hulk
originally it was something
whenever I see his name I was like uh
the Hulk
yeah it's now the hulks in this one
um but yeah um Lou Ferreira I mean he is
a brilliant actor I loved him actually
in swat he played a drunken swap
um and he was great in that as well he
is a genuinely good actor obviously
he was in Breaking Bad
um obviously we've got Rush who who is
who's British so of course he's a good
actor
um I would even say Eli and we would we
were talking before the stream about
um Lou Diamond Phillips who is a
brilliant actor and he played Telford
who was always my favorite character
because that's where I'm from
lvp for the next 20 minutes if you want
to just do that for a stream I'd be
perfectly fine with that go no
um
Phillips is one of the most underrated
actors Iris think he's he told us I mean
but you can you know he's a popular
actor because he's in everything but um
but yeah he's oh
Camille oh oh uh uh Ming now when when
she was still just going by Mina you
know
love me perfect actress for it and and
y'all said she wasn't in there that much
she was she she was like three or four
episodes less uh and she's not like as
pivotal all the time but she she hits
hard every time she comes on screen she
was pretty pivotal early on but it
her character got pushed back I think a
little bit um when you become used to
Ming now when in Mandalorian sorry book
above Affair and More in Agents of
Shield when she actually just played
this Kick-Ass character she's she's not
that in this she's
um a politician more character she's you
know um I think so yeah they didn't use
as well as they could have done
um
well with it nonetheless honestly
because I'm used to her and all those
badass kind of characters she's she's
Mulan you know like that's it's what you
kind of expect but
I liked it Roblox
because as soon as you're good at
something
you stop being Scottish you stop being
British if he was a crap actor he'd be
scottishing him
that's how it works in this country
um the guy that won the tennis I'm not
very I don't really know tennis I forget
his name he won Wimbledon no no the
British guy he was struck right up until
he won Wimbledon and then he became
British
that's how it works that's how it works
my friend it makes sense yeah um but
Robert Carlisle is a great actor so um
the acting I like though the most and it
was a character that I really enjoyed
was the guy that Greer
um yeah absolutely freaking nutty and oh
completely
okay I I started out the show really not
liking Greer and really not liking
Colonel young I ended the show loving
both of them but like I still
I didn't cringe when they were on screen
that's not the right word it's more like
I uh every time I saw Louis Ferreira on
screen because he was he was a great
actor I just really didn't like that
character and his decision making and I
was just every time I was like oh God
he's gonna do something dumb he's gonna
do something that's gonna piss me off oh
God he's gonna hurt the crew you know
whatever is gonna happen uh it wasn't
cringe I was more
you know like don't don't do something
dumb like we're trying to survive here
we
want the SGU folk to live but
I don't think his goal was to live I was
always hoping that Greer would kill
everyone in the sleep at the same time
yeah Greer started off that way and by
the end I felt like I mean they didn't
really
push his story as much but they did it
in the background in like the most
perfect of ways where him and Dr Parker
together now Dr Park's blind so there's
a whole different thing that they could
be working on there there were so many
things that could have been a season
three four five
um
I think MBK here makes it an instant
Point says you were uncomfortable by the
characters and that was the point
exactly
the
post to feel
claustrophobic it was the first real
dark and limited and a little it was
supposed it was a show that was supposed
to make you feel uncomfortable opposed
to Stargate sg1 and SGA which were big
and open I could go lucky right and
interest you know I think
um so yeah again maybe that was the
problem
do you think so no let's talk about the
characters a little bit more then so it
was
Something's Happened now we're back now
there's something in
um it was their actors were there too
many
main characters no because of the one of
the comments that we just got is Adam
Brody was the best character he would
have been any of the other Stargate
shows and I I think that's why Adam
Brody is not one of the first nine
people in the cast he's in the first
maybe 16 17 18 people in the cast but I
could I I think I could name more part
of it's because it's more fresh and I
just watched this but I think I could
name more Stargate Universe characters
than I could in either of the other
shows and I I feel like the same might
be for a lot of people generally that
we're a lot more main characters because
they had nowhere to go other characters
who initiate they could come and go a
little bit SGA less but they could come
and go a little bit but I'm my point is
like what Bob said here
um Chloe was a walking passive
aggressive Disaster Area most the female
characters are too stereotype now I
think that might have been a thing of
the time or whatever maybe you know
um maybe that's true a little bit
TJ was a passive aggressive bag of a
disaster area as well I thought I hated
the TJ character the whole thing between
here and young irritated me and it was
boring way too long
um but Chloe was
boring whiny
character that that's just she did my
head in I was like what are you gonna
complain about now Chloe and she just
she was
dead died so what get on with it you
know it's just like honestly she I'm not
actually irritated me so much
um I have to try to
delete her from my brain
well okay season one I can see that uh
yeah Elise Levesque she's a great
actress if you haven't seen ready or not
that's that's good yeah it is good uh
I I can see that for season one but I
feel like that was necessary for where
she went in season two because I thought
she was a lot better in season two where
yeah she is kind of like relegated to
the side for for parts of times she is
one of the main and pivotal characters
for like the events going on every time
anything big happens she's right there
either alongside a bunch of aliens or
she's helping the math and science next
to Eli and and rush you I I guess
she's not your typical TV character and
that's this remember we were talking
about how like SGU was kind of the
bridge of where TV changed a lot uh and
and Game of Thrones came right after it
was ever slightly a little bit before
its time SG yeah I I think it was it was
politely missed
it was the breaking point for TV and in
a good way it was like we got to stop
doing what we've been doing since the
60s and let's do something
different and and the whole TV
landscape's changed and tone and the way
everything looks on TV uh we we're used
to more like eight six six to 12 TV
episodes instead of 12 to 24 and this
are the way we look at things have
changed since literally SGU which is
cool uh because it was the last like 20
episode show that I can really think of
that had like even a darker tone like
that you know uh more mature tone yeah
on linear well what does linear TV look
like since yesterday you left literally
linear TV has gotten shite since more
and more every year in the UK that's um
uh Sky reshone it and it's back to get
its own channel on
um privy so the other question there
would be to ask how well it's done on
streaming since it left honestly because
those were on Netflix then and and Hulu
time and a couple others
do you think that if this show had been
just a couple of years later even if it
got canceled by MGM that this would have
been at the perfect sort of show that
Netflix would have picked up
but it was maybe yeah a little bit early
completely because like literally one of
I I only watched this show on Netflix
because of Katie Sackhoff and a couple I
do like a couple of the ancillary cast
members
did you watch another life on Netflix
when it came out I tried because it came
off was in it awful it was bad I like
the concepts and then I like Katie sack
off I think I watched two episodes
and then once the whole it being Katie
Sackhoff thing
I'm such a massaging I'm terrible I'm
like oh pretty lady and as soon as that
sort of stopped being fun I'd stop
watching
I just adore the actors and I I like the
guy that played her husband as well so I
was like yeah I'm doing it I watched a
season I gotta finish it this was my
mindset there was it worth finishing
probably not but uh I need to be like
that mate and I've something good might
happen I must watch this to the end and
yeah I'm a bit more seasoned I'm like
this is crap I'm not watching it anymore
my life has gone I haven't got enough
hours in the day for this nonsense and I
just like so I've
yeah I used to I used to push through
things but now I've got kids
I'm too LCD for that I'm like I just
gotta yeah finish yeah uh but but that's
arguably
SGU 2.0 in a lot of ways because it's
not necessarily like okay well we got
these guys and I I guess if SGU came
back they could totally
take a couple of elements from that
series and and use them already better
than that series could ever presented
them uh not could have ever presented
them but the way they did present them
just the people in Korea where you okay
maybe we get to if we get a movie for
Stargate and they actually do get the
the destiny at a certain point
the
maybe you can't bring everybody back so
and that's a good way to wait to like
all your actors have their schedules
cleared out as well it's like okay maybe
we can only bring like three or four
people back and maybe it's not your main
main guys maybe Colonel young maybe a
couple of the individuals from the
citizens kind of aspect of things gets
released first and they're like yeah
we're not taking young out yet leave him
in there you know
of having an issue with like uh think I
want to come back to that if that's all
right yeah so I'm gonna we're gonna end
the chat and we'll think about how
would it bring how could we bring it
back and what we're doing I've got an
idea that's going to be incredibly
unpopular
some of the story lines I always say
that the first season was pretty
forgettable it was it the first season
of the drones with the berserk of drones
was that the second no that's the second
season
right so that this it's been a few years
since I've watched it so I'm gonna
forgive me
um
what actually happened in the first
season the Lucian Alliance stuff was the
second season as well wasn't it yeah uh
uh Lutheran Alliance stuff was great I
really enjoyed those few episodes and
the attack on Earth I thought was was
fun I thought it was good how they I
liked how to Colonel um how Telford was
sort of turned and they used the Mind
Control technology that was cool
um I really I really liked how that got
caught up
um I really loved um the guy that played
varro I thought he's good I've seen him
a few things he's he's really cool he
was in both sg1 and SGA right I believe
it was yeah um but he's been in low to
sci-fi over the years he plays military
guys a lot and things like that yeah
yeah
who played Kiva who's one of my favorite
actresses she's a Great British actress
she got famous because she um when the
first
um uh
I told you earlier what was it called
the Tomb Raider movies came out yeah
yeah she was Laura Croft yeah she put
they hired actresses to play Lara Croft
for like you know photo shoots and
advertisements and things and that's
actually how she became famous
um but then she was in things like
Boston Legal
um she was in she did that movie the um
the reboot of the werewolf movie with
the vampires
uh uh underworld stuff or no well so
they did underworld
um Awakening
I think it might oh e-boot anyway so it
was a prequel brilliant
um it actually showed how the how the
war started sort of thing in that so and
she played the
um that's Lucian as well so lucian's
love interest that was a vampire anyway
she played that she's great in that
she's a fantastic actress and she's
gorgeous
um so you know I I'm on board with that
um
so yeah so she was in the prequel for
that
um kind of a prequel
it was set in the past so yeah
um but anyway
um Robert knepper who played Simeon who
was um tea bag in um
in
Escape Escape thing that escape series
Prison Break
he's been in so much sci-fi as well over
the years he's a fantastic actor he was
great for just a few episodes that that
happened oh that happened season two as
well uh because lucian's what actually
happened in season one
I don't remember
well that's why you probably find it so
boring and slow is because it's it's
setting up everything it's it's that's
the it's it takes its time
22 Episodes
setting stuff up it's six months of
Television to set stuff up do we do not
think that maybe that's the problem
well in the first series how did the
first season end
uh
it was it was the how they I guess that
was was it right when they figured out
Telford was a a mole or a rat kind of or
then that goes straight into the Lucian
Alliance yeah uh
okay so so I my mindset's a little
different on this because I grew up with
Ahsoka Tano in the Clone Wars uh and yes
it's animated but it it it'sok is maybe
my second or third favorite Star Wars
character in general just because at
this point I've had seven years plus
Rebel so essentially three or four extra
years on top of that 11 years of
Television right there
plus now we've got a little uh there's a
great Soca novel but now we got live
action Ahsoka too there's she started
off as the most annoying abrasive
god-awful character that you ever have
seen and they they take her on a journey
specifically to like making you hate her
at first to make her that much better
whenever she actually kind of becomes a
fully realized person I think Chloe and
and TJ are are good examples of that
because by season two TJ and varro
that's one of my favorite little
storylines in there Chloe with all of
her math stuff the alien stuff like that
that would have come into play later I
think those are two of the best
characters in the second season but they
had to be
like that in the first season I that
part of that was
now you can kind of do that with most
characters back then it was mostly
female characters and that was kind of
delegated to and and uh if I'm giving
the Star Wars example they did the same
thing with Ezra Bridger and Star Wars
Rebels later on and then that was
allowing Ahsoka to kind of be a teacher
at times allowed Cannon Jairus the other
Jedi guy to be a teacher they were
able to do that I think with that Series
in a much smaller amount of time where
that took maybe two or three seasons to
really get like Ahsoka down down uh
season two I thought both those
characters were great
it just took a lot of a little hampering
to get there you know
yeah but it shouldn't take it shouldn't
take a full but we shouldn't really sit
here now talking about two seasons of
Stargate SGU and go what happened in the
first season and you watched a couple of
months ago and not I'm not not putting
your stuff here but yeah you can't tell
me what happened
what was it was boring not because it's
boring because it it plays together in a
certain way I think it was it plays out
exactly how it's written I don't I don't
I think I don't know you know I I
wouldn't necessarily it might be boring
to some of course but it is
very I think it was it was portrayed and
depicted exactly how it was written uh
it feels
like there shouldn't be a gap there so
that's part of why I don't think that
that it's like it's not where like
we in season three of this or in season
two of this there is that continuous
story which we continue and I think
that's that's better than okay well
there was this big break and then like
they picked up two months later and they
found all this fruit on this one world
and they've been living off fruit for
the last two months and now I'm back
with the crew of the destiny no I I like
that it was continuous and it feels more
it feels less episodic and more like a
film in that way uh which I like I like
yeah so the Lucian line stuff came in
towards the end of season one like
Stephanie says and then that sounds
right to me
um the thing right so so a little while
ago I did a video because a lot of
people coming on and saying look and I
started a bit of an argument about SGU
and I said look it's my least favorite
out of the three and I found it boring
so I thought right I'm gonna go back and
I'm gonna watch the first three episodes
and the first two episodes are stunning
they're they're exciting they're
action-packed the story there's
confrontation and there's everything
and but it's a three-parter basically
the third the opening yeah three parts
the third part
when they're walking through the desert
for 90 of the episode
is boring and for me that's how they
carried on then for the next about 15
episodes
whereas really they were exploring the
destiny okay fine they thought oh look
we found a shuttle
um fine oh look bloody Rush has been
hiding something else the tinker and
that's how it went on
for three months of my life
okay binging after the fact is a lot
different of course but during that time
I'd argue that
going on that planet like that that that
was bringing it back to core Stargate
were you so excited about the
differences that whenever it went back
to its normality that it just didn't
feel succinct enough
no it was just boring they didn't do
anything
they were there to look for
something they needed was it for the air
scrippers or something I forget it was
only a couple months ago I needed
something from the air scrubbers was
lighter but it it was something I think
it was water it was water they were
looking for water at the time it wasn't
just water
um so they're searching the look in the
thing and the one the the one bit in
that episode I really did like was
something
um with Eli any sort of web yeah you've
destroyed it it did like um a Planet of
the Apes line and you know I really did
like her I thought that was quite funny
the Charlton housing the quote
um but other than that it's a very very
forgettable episode I mean I know
there's a bit the degree steps up in
that episode and we see him
um actually that he's more he's a more
complicated character than we ever
thought I like that we really start to
see that rush in that episode is not to
be trusted and young and rush really
our young is going to kill Rush at some
point that's when we first I think Young
at some point she's gonna put a bullet
in this man's head
um and you know and that's and that that
was the big that was the big driving
force for a lot of the first season was
at what point is Young going to kill
rush because it's going to happen and he
beats the crap out of him a couple of
times
but to me that was pretty much it was
about characters and it was about the
tension and there's the claustrophobia
but that was about it until the Lucian
Alliance storyline well don't forget
that was the first episode we had an
alien
it it was the reason they survived and
then or not it was it was a lot of it it
was all the little tiny bugs and insects
and stuff but they were the reason they
survived and that I guess introduced a
new aspect of the show similar to the
other ones of course but
and threw a wrench in their plans
so there's always I guess more to the
thing like I mean we're all remembering
it from from the past even me just
watching it a month ago you know it's
enough has gone by you know we're I've
watched half a dozen freaking things
since then where my brain's more on that
kind of stuff
there
I I like that it's still like like you
just said those were all really great
points it might have been a little bit
more boring of an episode comparative to
the first two but those were a lot of
really good things that typically make
up a good episode part of I think our
expectations is what hurts SGU in a lot
of ways uh but then subverting them is
what does so well with it I think at the
same time yeah that's fair enough right
it coming back
so an SGU conclusion that's what a lot
of people going about now I'm just going
to say that the Babylon 5 has been
talked about in the comments a little
bit it didn't take about my 520 Services
get you hooked S2 on SGA it's well
written I remember more
um yeah exactly um it didn't they were
much quicker Babylon five though the
first season of Babylon five you don't
have to watch it if you decide to watch
Babel if I bet you could skip the first
season pretty much
um the guy that played Sinclair sadly
got really poorly he wasn't he wasn't
well so they swapped him and we got
Sheridan
um who plays by Bruce Brock's letter
Bruce Brock slender
Bruce blocks in then
Bruce Banner Bruce Banner he played by
The Incredible Hulk
um brox letner Lightner the guy from
Tron so
um and for me that's when the show
really kicked off it got loads better
but I really liked
the guy from Tron
um because I thought he's obviously he's
just one of those actors liked it I
loved him in the Scarecrow Mrs King
before that and I just thought it was
great in it
um Bruce box Lightner
um
but you do have to watch the first
series because then actually the whole
thing with
um
Sinclair does become reporting you
another blindness talking about but
anyway
um
it's more contextual than it is like
story driven in a way yeah no there's a
big part of the story with Babylon 4
that's to do with
um Sheridan uh to do a Sinclair so if
you don't watch the first season when he
does come back when he's well enough you
won't know the bloody what's going on
but anyway my point is that we're about
to get a Babylon five
animated movie oh I know where this is
going now so
we think and this is just to think this
is me and cutting two and two together
and I'm maybe getting six but I may be
getting four we don't know but we think
possibly Warner Brothers is going to be
the studio partner for Amazon
and that they'll be making a few things
together potentially Robocop and
whatever it might also be part of this
I I'm hearing more and more Whispers
from the people I speak to that Amazon
really want to sign a multi-year
multi-project deal with one of these big
studios and you really have a partner
for the next decade the projects
so that means that Stargate might be
made by Warner Brothers that's the video
I did a couple of days ago and we're
talking about okay I remember that in
one of the things that Warner Brothers
does well is the animated movies
right and Babylon 5 is going to come
back with them now they can't do a
Babylon 5 live action
episode because a lot of the actors that
appeared in Babylon 5 have sadly passed
away so a lot of the actors are now gone
um at Delan the actress to play Delan is
a major character in Babylon 5. so you
cannot have and if nothing else they're
all 20 years older as well even the
actors that survive are much much older
we've got a similar problem with SGU
that there's been a big gap
so if we got a conclusion to SGU
if it was an animated movie and that was
the only way it could be done
would that be the worst thing in the
world oh
we could get all the actors back any
actors that have passed away or that are
unavailable could be done by somebody
else because they could get somebody to
come in and do the voice the age thing
doesn't matter
um
it would be much much cheaper because
one of the things I keep saying about
SGU is it wasn't as popular as this year
on SGA
so if they're going to invest a big
money into doing this and this is me
thinking very practically it's not what
I want
um it's me thinking practically
um
it would be much much cheaper to do an
animated movie than it would be to do a
live action movie or something else and
a lot less risk
if you're not me
is that is that the way to do it is that
is it the only way we could get a
conclusion to SGU I actually don't think
that would not be a risk I think that'd
be the most risky thing they could ever
do and
I think that would
sorry Kevin I would hate that actually I
would love a Stargate animated series
maybe maybe if that's the series that we
get while they're making live action
films for a little bit that might be
something I'm not saying that this is as
long as as well as all the other things
when I said this I got a load of
comments for people saying animation
I'm saying no live action as well this
is as well yes yes but I don't think
SGU is a good spot for uh like like we
were talking about the other day I think
if if stargate's gonna do a movie it
needs to involve SGU SGU is the only one
that's legitimately primed for a film
and that's because of the way the
television show was like like we
struggled for a second figuring out
we're season one and two
happened because it's still one
continuous story compared where like we
end here we pick up here we end here we
pick up here it it feels
and I I think the acting's just fine in
sg1 and SGA but the actors and and the
acting in that show are
just because of the type of show it is
Leaps and Bounds better than what we get
in SG-1 and SGA it's not as fun of
course it's not as like jovial but
by technicality the SGU does
truly have like the the higher class of
acting not necessarily actors but acting
uh
it's it's the only thing Prime for a
movie I I think as and I'll be in the
minority for this because obviously
we're all Stargate fans we just want it
back and if we can have our sg1 and SGA
members back oh oh we want them and I do
too but I I argue just coming from the
film mind that I have being in La et
cetera Etc what happened to Destiny it
flew into a story
if they find you a star they're better
off what do you mean they were stuck
between two galaxies unless it's a rogue
star in the middle and it's not gonna
happen Mike yeah
like everybody type space yeah
I'm not very good
I I just feel like SGU is the only one
legitly primed for a movie and just
trying to be objective trying to look at
it because I live out in Hollywood and
Bs yada yada so knowing just the people
and the type of people that live out
here and make the decisions they do uh
my mentor that convinced me to move out
here that's playwright and and I'm
producing plays for him right now his
wife ran Liv and Maddie on on uh Disney
Channel the number one Disney show for a
decade uh so I get to talk with them and
kind of understand like a producer's
mindset every now and then which
hopefully will make me a good producer
one day you know but uh
just just that mindset there
sg1 and SGA if the actors act like they
did in the TV shows in a movie they're
done immediately like literally I I as
much as I love even the older cast all
of sg1 I would put them all back in
acting school prior to getting on a set
every single one and I don't mean that
in a bad way that's not enough
I agree with you in one way that a movie
is very different to a TV series and the
importance of it acting is different
but they have a lot more time to get
scenes right in a movie than they do in
a series
in a movie it's I want you to you know
have a bit of an inflection of I mean
look at Star Trek the Next Generation
when that stepped up to a movie it
worked
yes and no on that because you have more
time to focus on the things that you
really want but on a film set you are
liable to get your sides like the day of
like you you might have a TV you have
much longer rehearsal time because you
have this allocated time in movies
I had to disagree with you but on this
one just like your greatest TV sci-fi TV
show ever you're wrong that I mean
sometimes they would get the script the
day before and they would pick but I'm
talking about when they were doing 22
Episodes
in it you know doing 16 hour days yeah
they would get their Pages the day
before and they were expected to do it
the next day
same thing with film same very same
thing with film had a bit longer with
film a proper cinematic you know with
that don't get me wrong I'm sure there
are films that it is like CT pants the
best example was Iron Man Iron Man they
were riding like the hour prior to like
they had to like keep going back and
stuff they were the the writer old Mark
Fergus or whatever was it Mark Fergus
right yeah yeah he's not writing that
movie I I know he's credited as it and
it and I do like the guy for a lot of
the things he's done but he did not
write that movie John Favreau wrote that
movie and Kevin feige did it was [__]
and fabric that should have been the
writers on that because they were
rewriting it literally on the hour I
mean I think I've read those stories but
um
yeah and Mark Fergus was on set as well
and they kept throwing ideas at him and
he was kept constantly rewriting so Mark
Fergus did write it and did all that I
didn't know that part you're right Kevin
feige and and Jean Favre were there
throwing stuff at him constantly and
they were constantly rewriting
um thank you so so much William for your
contribution what intrigued me about
sgus Rush seems to be more driven about
finding the meaning of life in the
universe and sg1 rsga character
a rush was driven to the point of being
psychotic
I think Russia is my favorite Stargate
character
oh well that's the next 20 minutes of
Our Lives um
explained that one over Richard Dean
Anderson's Colonel O'Neil 2 else or
teals or as much as I love them they're
just going through the motions I I I
love all those characters so much I
adore those characters but they're just
going through the motions Rush
immediately fit into this universe that
I I was 15 years of the making uh this
beautiful great universe that was put
together and then not only did he fit
into it he gave it purpose and not just
purpose for himself purpose for not just
the destiny crew purpose for the SGC uh
and then of course he throws some
hampers in there not necessarily him but
the Lucian Alliance just being there and
taking part in certain things adds to
the storyline of what's going on but
and Russia's a ghoul looking for
ultimate power that would be funny but
it he he's very like
just he he is I I don't even know how to
say it correctly like he's Rush is is
Robert it's the only thing that Robert
Carlisle could do uh he's just he's
great
uh thinking about it
um now of course not it's all opinion we
all have a right to our own opinion so
now I can find my way back into what
happened yeah but he's just wrong
um I I did like how the reason I like
Russia's character and I did like
Russia's character was that he there was
lots of different aspects going on with
him he was there was it was a
three-dimensional character the acting
obviously was excellent Robert Carlisle
is a hell of an actor
um and yeah there's a lot going on there
he's not my favorite character in
Stargate by a long ways not even my
favorite character in SGU
probably Eli was
I'm gonna go with you at night actually
there's a lot of very dislikable
characters on SGU I didn't like young I
didn't like tell foot at times I didn't
like Russia times but you're not
supposed to yeah like Eli is like he was
but he was there to be likable that's
that was his point
you're supposed to like him that's why
the end of sdu is so heartbreaking
because you like him and he's sacrificed
himself in some ways
it was great
imperfect characters uh nowhere near
over just said and I think that's what
made where I I know I pissed off a
couple people by saying everybody else
was going through the motions yes tilt
did fight his own God but he fought his
own God on everybody else's time not on
his time on everybody else's time that
he's going through the motions by
definition I love it but he's going
through the motions it's not like I'm
getting a task force I'm going to take
down uh do an entire video talking about
the inconsistencies with Teal's
character
and how he sort of like how we got to ep
season was it I was halfway through
season one or might have been two well
we suddenly find out he's got a wife and
a kid and we're like yeah bro what you
were like that that wasn't important
whenever you just like hopped off this
thing and just started an entire life
like
it's yeah that was inconsistent with
what you know and it's the same thing
with all the main characters I think the
most consistent the two most consistent
like main characters
actually three uh because John Shepard
would be consistent but I think it would
be Shepard Rodney and Sam are are the
three most consistent characters
throughout their like longevity of
Stargate and honestly after that would
be like
assistant Daniel was pretty consistent
and not really they they they yes and
like they grew as people and they grew
in their closeness towards each other uh
but but I I they're a consistent and
growth yes but they weren't like I guess
the same characters from the beginning
to the end uh which is good you don't
want them to necessarily be the same
characters where I I think Carter
Shepard and Rodney are probably still
the same characters from beginning to
end and Hammond is fits in that too
there it is Heaven's great
he's Texas
he's just that's one of the reasons why
that I'm talking about if they did an
animated movie but he's already dead in
in the universe they make the comment in
SGA but that's just just to round off
that animated thing because then we we
wandered off awesome yeah yeah one way
to move thing I'd like to see it because
we could have an actual SG-1 episode set
set
20 years ago sort of thing you know set
within the sg1 series we can get that
sort of thing with animated that we
can't get with live action
totally we could get something with
Hammond in we could get something with
you we could get something where Hammond
where we see Hammond die
if the family agreed the family of the
actual actor would have to agree that's
something but we could get something
like that we could we could get episodes
that we can't get through live action
that's my point with the animated which
is why Warner Brothers are the partner
that does open some possibilities I
don't want to see another animated
cartoon kids show
um
in the vein of Star Trek like I don't
think I don't think comedy is the right
route and I don't think
I I think clone wars and Rebels is a
good basis for like the story arcs I
don't think the the childlike aspect
should be uh mimics or or encouraged
um one of the things giant freaking Robo
got slammed for a lot was they've
released the stories about two years ago
saying that basically MGM we're going to
do a live action in an animated series
and that I found out since that actually
was true they didn't think with giant
freaking robot as normal they were six
months behind
truth
and it had already become absolutely but
the new um chief executive MGM came in
Chris uh Michael Wright and he basically
went like our MGM the reason why MGM
wanted to do it was because they wanted
to try and get the animated Studios back
up and running so they thought we need
projects for The Animation Studios and
one of them says what we'll do a live
action star getting more follow-up but
look how well lower decks is doing and
that was the argument
um so they were seriously thinking about
doing it luckily Amazon came what no
Michael Wright came in and went our
Animation Studios crap what are you
talking about let's just focus on
something we can do we can do a Stargate
live action series let's get Brad
writing let's do some and that's what
that's turned into that plan
um
the thing is though if they Warner
Brothers do it we're going to get the
live action series we're going to get
the movies but we could also get some
animated projects that just can't be
done with live action and they shouldn't
do anything they could do live action if
they could do live action they should
just do it live action but if there is a
story or something that we can't do
live action and I'm thinking in
conclusion to SGU is possibly one of
those
let's get an animated movie as well
something along the lines what Babylon 5
is doing now which is made by Warner
Brothers
you know we're getting an episode which
is not physically possible to do it in
live action
animated movie I'm doing a video about
this tomorrow so I'm completely ruining
ruining my the video I'm gonna argue to
them
Hello Nurse
um Hello Nurse
um I just love that cartoon and a nurse
with long legs
the anime exercise
um but you know I I honestly think
there's a lot of like stories they could
tell
from sg1
or SGA to fill in the blanks type of
thing
I guess it could be yeah
a mini series like that or something
like or along those lines uh would be
cool
um I see I love the animation idea I
think they'd have to go uh
in in it had to be an adult animation in
the sense of like
uh gindy tarkovsky's Primal or his new
series unicorn Warriors Eternal uh which
just kind of sounds funny but it is an
adult animated series but it's not it's
not adult in like a crass kind of way
it's not adult and like uh
some like we're gonna go super dark and
just beat everybody and gonna be some
bloody anime or something like
I mean I wouldn't be super opposed if it
was an anime type of style Stargate
honestly uh but it needs to be
somewhere between TV 14 and team mature
I I feel like uh I don't like the idea
of an SGU animated finish up uh
um
but it's like you said would the actors
want to return for animation
I would argue maybe because it's a
paycheck and they go in for about three
days
and it's done
and at least that might that that would
at least open the door for Live Action
returns as well uh one option as well
you can do something that concludes it
that brings everyone home and then all
of a sudden Russian whatever can appear
in the live action stuff because it
could be set eight years ago
the animated movie could be set not long
at any point we could bring through make
a Canon is the point make it Cannon I'll
caveat everything right there
cruel I still don't like the idea of a
movie I I had to laugh sorry I laughed
in the middle of everything you were
saying uh Matt said Dana Mae Jackson in
there and I
know uh
uh
uh what was I just about to say
completely forgot oh oh oh uh nope it
was there for a second
um
there's some oh oh that's a I'm on it
now
animation wise
um
That's funny though uh what are we gonna
do today Harris we're gonna do the same
as we do every day I'm gonna take over
the world but of course through stargaze
of course
I I would I would not mind I would not
like an SGU animated film I don't want
that I I just think that almost
just puts puts a hamper on everything I
I don't know I I feel like that would be
just as detrimental as like oh that
could be good you know I feel like it
could be just as bad if if not like
really just put a hamper on Stargate
coming back you know because that's
that's an event and we we need those we
need a film if we're gonna get a film we
need an event and and that would be the
type of thing to do that yeah the
animated movie if they did an animation
it cannot be what kick-starts this
franchise
what if they did an animated Stark like
you just said and what if they did an
animated Stargate Universe but were able
to fill in the gaps of the last 10 15
years and that might show okay well now
these actors got out thin these actors
might be available now for Live Action
so we can kind of work that series
around how we want to it would be a way
for them all to age and everybody pops
out at their current age I mean I mean
Ming now win still looks like Mina from
back then so she could she could still
be in the stasis I suspect she might be
a vampire
oh yeah her and Paul Rudd are vampire
evil thing I mean God don't know she's
not changing People she's at all she's
like that was it Dorian Gray from them
yeah she's straight up the picture
Dorian Gray just yeah about the painting
of her somewhere that's really elderly
she's I mean she's amazing it's just
gorgeous but um Mulan will never die
you must have our own snakes this spot
is what we're saying
um but yeah meanwhile Wayne could come
back and still play the same character
exactly the same and it wouldn't be an
issue at all but the rest of them can't
I um David blew good
he's just got skinnier and I would just
say well yeah because it's not enough
food done yeah yeah that might work
um you know so
yeah
Ozarks that's your question they could
use animated movies if they do it
cleverly in lots of ways to tell the
story that then leads into other things
but it's I'm just I'm going to go back
to that main point I'm saying though
they can't do projects with animation
that they could do live actions they
could do it live action they should do
it live action yes but there are things
they can't do with live action
animated would an SGU fill in the Gap
series work
yeah why not yeah I feel like that's the
type of thing these animated movies they
can be done really fast we could go from
announcing it to six months and it could
be on a it could be you know DVD sales
boom Babylon five
um it's about it was they were doing the
voices just before Christmas and it's
out in in July
that turnover is great a movie will take
at least two years an animated movie
eight or nine months because they're
using the same stuff that Warner
Brothers are using for lots and lots of
other projects it'll be this exactly the
same technology a lot of it's Warner
Brothers yes
because because Amazon's taking a long
time with uh just animated movies Amazon
themselves have taken a long time like
War of the rohiram for Lord of the Rings
uh Dave they've been working on that for
like three years four years now you
cannot fold them
I I I I want to say new line is part of
it but I I'm not positive if new line is
part of it that keeps me very happy
because new line is is who I think
should have Lord of the Rings most of
the time
yeah they they're generally doing a good
job of that but that's that's the
problem is that I'll just come up with
the Lord of the Rings cartoon from
thingy from the 1978 movie uh
I can't remember what it's done called
agents building Atlantis and Destiny
would also be a great one yeah and
Warner Brothers animation
yeah new line Cinemas Warner Brothers
animation and solar entertainment and it
will be distributed by Warner Brothers
Pictures to me mate that's just another
nail in the thing that it's going to be
Warner Brothers they're going to be
making this show
I'm with you that that was like my last
question I guess that would like
mentally hold me back from thinking that
but now I'm like
every time I do a video that does well I
get a load of comments saying you
haven't got any sources you're talking
[__] I've had a couple of people tell me
this is a possibility and but a couple
of people that work in the industry are
saying look at all the deals we don't
know what's going on because the thing
is as well and I I should have said this
in the video the other day when I talked
about Warner Brothers the reason why if
this is true that it will it will be a
dead secret until it gets announced is
because this will massively affect
Amazon's um stock price and it will
massively affect Warner Brothers stock
price
and they are not allowed to leak stuff
about this because they can get done for
like um stock price manipulation yeah
whenever there's a massive deal like
this it is kept very hush and they take
it serious they like leaks about
Stargate I know for a fact that there
I've been told stuff that has been
authorized by Amazon that Amazon have
told people that they can they can talk
about it
and leaks to deadline leaks to me leaks
to other places and and that's true for
lots of projects over the years that's
not that's not special yeah the the big
professional they like stuff to get out
there
stuff like this so they don't and they
take you seriously and if if Amazon are
about to sign what will be a billion
dollar project with Warner Brothers a
deal with with Warner Brothers to say
that we are going to be Cinema partners
for the next 10 years you can see Warner
Brothers stock price will go
oh yeah and they cannot they cannot let
it leak they can't
so I'm getting people talk to me saying
watch this
it's Warner Brothers initially people
talk to me I got told a while ago so
look at Sony because if it really is
penguin in the Parker it'll be Sony
um and that that's not them basing on
something they know they're just saying
look two and two together look guys this
this makes sense this is people that
work in the industry that said this
makes sense watch this
everybody for last six months has said
to me Warner Brothers so if we go Warner
Bros that means no penguin Parker
maybe most most likely at least
My worry is
genuinely and this is not me trying to
scare Monger anyone but Bad Robot
pitched
twice for Stargate we know they did
Jenny stiven has told us as confirmed
that they've confirmed twice right they
pitched a movie we got to we got to
Glimpse that movie because I actually I
can say this now because
um they don't work there anymore and
it's safe I actually spoke to somebody
that when they did the pitch they put
these packs together
and they distribute it to like
Executives and things I know that I
spoke to the person that printed them
so um that actually actually physically
put them together right
um that's what all my sources they're
never anybody high up they're always
like janitors and [__] but anyway
um
but I I can say that now because they
don't work there anymore and they don't
talk to me anymore either absolutely
because they don't they're working so
they left the industry completely they
do something completely different now
okay okay
um
this person actually put it together now
their pitch was and I say and we knew
what I think this is the whole thing
about ra coming back and blah blah blah
it was blown out the water all right I
got called a liar then because I was
saying it's going to be a movie first
and I got called the liar by a bunch of
people I'm like yeah yeah shock it's
gonna be amazing
um but anyway
um but I know they've pitched again in
about August
right but we don't know what that pitch
was we don't know what happened with
that one because unfortunately my
sources moved on by then but um and we
know Fergus was at least talking in
December we know Fergus was talking at
that point but it fell down about
Christmas then my problem is Bad Robot
has an exclusive deal with Warner
Brothers
it's at least another year it's at least
till
but there's already talk about it
potentially being renewed
a year ago they were talking about suing
them
right Warner Brothers is generally
talking about suing bad right because
they'd made nothing nothing yeah
yeah the 500 partly because of covid
part because of other things but they
just made nothing now let's talk about
it being renewed right what is that
conversation about renewing it being
based on is it being based on the fact
the Bad Robot have got the Stargate
franchise
and now I don't know that I'm but I'm
that's what I'm concerned about I'm
worried about
what on Earth are Warner Brothers
talking to Bad Robot about what other
project a Bad Robot doing there I know
they're involved in a couple of movies
but apparently their involvement is
is minor
um there is a couple of sci-fi movies
coming up the Bad Robot are going to be
producing for Warner Brothers
um in cooperation with a couple of other
people
um but but what an exclusivity deal with
one Brothers though what the hell are
they signing so my fear is they pitched
once they got batted back
they pitched again basically because
Warner Brothers told them to
it it makes sense
and maybe Bad Robot were successful and
don't forget a Bad Robot could work in
conjunction with penguin and Parker
because penguin and Parker might just do
the
um development work they'll still be
look at how many production companies
are involved for the expanse it was
about five
it's possible
I want to throw up
um so I I honestly think this is a risk
I actually like the idea of Warner
Brothers being involved with this I
think it gives MGM
lots of options and MGM has a good
working relationship with with
um Warner Brothers already like I say I
keep talking about the Creed trilogy but
there's loads of other projects as well
but the cree Trilogy was done in
cooperation with Warner Brothers
um
I just think the relationships there
I think they've got the studio space
they've got the expertise it gives them
other options like the animated stuff
my fear is
that robot
but Bad Robot I've done some good stuff
they have done some good stuff they've
also though done some utter [__] and any
of the good stuff they've diluted
further on which is the bad thing none
of their stuff stays good like they
might have a decent I that's that's the
thing I can't stand the fact the bad
reboot decides to do
sci-fi all the freaking time they don't
like sci-fi there's nothing about them
that likes sci-fi they like taking
proven good science fiction and turning
it into popcorn
yeah
[__] off sorry but like
um
care about what they're doing walk
through the other Star Trek project JP
Abrams will be producer but it cannot be
Bad Robot because Bad Robot
only works with Warner Brothers for the
next 18 months so it it can't be it that
was going to be a different production
company it was going to be uh I forget
the name of it now but um and it was
probably going to do through secret
hideout but JJ Abrams is going to be
producing
no it's not better for Star Trek so the
the only other thing that I was well I
was trying to hold back like a hairball
popping out from all the Bad Robot talk
there uh
it could be because Paramount in in like
literally just the first quarter of this
last year lost 1.23 billion dollars and
they're losing a lot more and Paramount
plus is not successful and they very
well might start handing out their stuff
do you think Bad Robot has just redone
their Star Trek stuff and now paramounts
bring it on to Warner Brothers maybe
they're releasing their like grasp on it
I mean I I do think at the moment
there's the Star Trek stuff is a bit
complicated because there are obviously
at the moments with secret hideout which
is um Alex kurtzman
there was a lot of conversation about
six months ago
that a lot of produce a lot of people at
Paramount are not massively happy with
what's going on with Star Trek and that
makes sense because the the the weird
very divided what's going on Star Trek
trekkies are like
I wouldn't even say it's half and half
people who really hate new track there
are people that hate it and there's
people who and that and obviously
producers and Executives look at that
and they go you know what what are we
doing wrong yeah and they look at Alex
Kirsten sometimes and I I know there are
people because I spoke to one that
actually does work at Paramount and he
said look there are people here that
want secret hideout gone but we've got a
contract with him and it would be
expensive to get rid of him and that's
the only reason he's hanging on and then
Picard season three came along Strange
New World did well and that that got him
a bit of a bit of um time but Picard
season three was actually hugely popular
and that has given basically kurtzman
the opportunity to do section 31 move in
to do this phase two thing so at the
moment Alex kurtzman is safe
okay but
it's safe with there's a lot he has
enemies apparently is it an exclusivity
deal do you know they have an exclusive
it's a deal okay okay
and Paramount
um so but that ends I think that ends
next year as well
um but there was a lot of rumors that
actually
it might they might they might pull Star
Trek away from secret hideout because
they're not happy about all of this and
that is still a risk but Picard season
three saved
it gave him a lot of time so I don't
think bad Rob was going to be getting
involved in Star Trek because I don't I
don't think they're going to move it
away from secret hideout just yet
but Paramount is losing money hand over
they have got this they have actually
got a lot of their um net debt down then
then that is is decreasing so they are
go ahead in the right way but Paramount
plus has not gone well
and it's expensive very important
the last season of strange new Worlds
cost 90 million dollars to produce oh
and that's not even talking about like
I don't know the type of money they're
spending on like Tulsa king or mayor of
East Town or these these smaller series
uh that are are amazing I still haven't
watched them I need to uh but are
supposed to be amazing
yeah but yeah they're not cheap and then
they also are doing like Halo
Halo is not cheap
that ain't cheap at all uh
uh no they're spending a lot of money
but they aren't forcing the the
Paramount guy and I mean David's aslaf
said the same thing as he says 2023 is
going to see the that's the peak of
spending on streaming from now on it's
going to be a downward Trend they're
going to be spending a lot less money
which we're already seeing do I Star
Wars calendars being stretched out um
Star Trek calendar was stretched out as
well and they pushed the discovery back
because they wanted to push everything
else back
so I mean
um and we're seeing that with Marvel as
well they're pushing yeah the spending
is going to be decreasing over the next
five years yeah
zazlov and uh Iger have been axing and
cutting and uh slowing things down
yeah
[Applause]
um so Arnold says I'm pretty sure there
is a second season of Halo
um they announced the second season
before the first season or before the
first season aired they're like we're
renewing it but because we already have
a bad reception on what's going on here
it's a whole new showrunner uh and it
might be two new showrunners and almost
human was brilliant oh I can't show it
oh stop doing that stupid singers with
them ah
stupid computer I'm right clicking
almost using was Almost Human was a
brilliant season I love that it got
canceled about halfway through and and
that was Carl Urban and uh I forgot the
guy's name we played the robot but it
was brilliant season if you ever go back
and watch it I think that I don't think
we've got eight episodes in the end but
it was or something like that but um
Paramount is not stable it's not stable
um it's credit people said it's it's got
It's B listed at the moment which is
means it's stable from a financial point
of view but with massive issues
um
it would not be surprising within two
years if we did not have Paramount plus
and that might be quicker than that
honestly for me there's going to be over
the next two or three years I think
we're going to get some big shock
announcements so certain of these
channels are going to be merging
together
and I actually think Netflix is going to
be the one that absorbs something like
Paramount Plus
and they'll just because Netflix is
dying for I like that and I mean if you
think about Paramount's IP under a
Netflix property it would kill
but anyway
no no this could be a whole different
conversation on topic we don't have to
dive too far but Netflix alone I feel
like
has to like I mean we're talking about
all these different streaming things
going down and joining other things but
I mean Netflix is
just strictly streaming I mean it's not
strictly streaming but it's just right
next door to strictly streaming I don't
feel like Netflix is going to last that
much longer if it keeps doing things the
way it's doing very significant debt but
they continue to increase there's a bit
of things got a bit scared for a second
didn't they win
um there was a decrease in their viewers
but then it bounced back immediately and
then apparently this the protocols have
been putting in place to stop people
sharing passwords has gone very well
so Netflix even though they have
significant debt they're still the
number one Disney has not been able to
overtake them and I I think they're
having a second wind personally
but guys like like we've had a brilliant
episode I'm saying I've got to go
because I promised the wife that um we
would have a nice meal this evening and
um I promised I'd be doing by half six
and I need a wee which is always the way
we end these episodes but before we go
have we settled the argument was SGU
brilliant
or was it boring yourself
well the last comment we had about SGU
was Su is the best Stargate series of
the whole franchise and also all my also
on my all-time favorite Sci-Fi series
shows ever made yeah
I don't think that encapsulates what we
talked about but I like that that's the
last thing we got we underrated yes it
was brilliant yes there you go I am
going to say
it was boring
but it was getting better and that's
basically a comment that we had before
we even started the Stream
saying argument over done and actually
he was right and it was like most big
sci-fi seasons
the first season struggled it was
Finding its feet and if MGM hadn't have
gone under we'd have got seven seasons
of it
would you say it was boringly brilliant
nope it was boring it was getting better
but it was horrible I'd say it was a
brilliant Point there's a slow burn and
there's a slow burn that was a smolder
but the smolder went on for a year it
was nice
I know you're not a big Slow Burn guy
you watch the movie first cow and then
come back to me okay I love that movie
and then I showed it
I find it boring ever again anyway I'm
an explosions popcorn
they're fun
talking really quickly I'm talking
really quickly because I'm gonna wipe
myself so guys thank you so so much for
getting into the um comments you've been
amazing as always we've had 70 80 90
people watching for the video fantastic
thank you so so much
um as always you are the reasons why we
do this so you're absolutely amazing
thank you so so much
um Harris thank you sir
we will be back next week with some
other marvelous episode probably talking
about Stargate gangs that's always seem
to talk about them that way so
hopefully with some news
guys see you soon bye see y'all
foreign
[Music]